we're at the foot of the Virunga
mountains and getting a briefing on how
to behave around the mountain gorilla
that's what everyone here has come to
see and they've paid one thousand five
hundred dollars each to spend one hour
with the great apes in their habitat are
you excited I am beyond excited this is
a international treasure that is being
protected in Rwanda and I'm so lucky to
be able to experience it I can't wait
and and and the cost is they put the
cost up what do you think about here
yeah I think I think that's fair it
limits access certainly to people who
can't afford it but I think by talking
about what the mountain gorillas are
providing for the communities that makes
a lot of sense this hike is not for the
faint of heart it's beautiful but
challenging terrain we trekked uphill
for over an hour
our guide Agustin shows us how gorillas
get their water and keeps the energy
high and then
right in front of us a family babies
mothers and the impressive great big
family man the silverback the young ones
are curious we have to move back not to
get too close others seemed almost bored
by our presence then a Display of power
we walk around to get another view
before we know it the hour is up and
it's time to trek back down Rhonda's
tourism policy we're told is one of low
volume high-value visitor numbers are
restricted and the price is high
translates to $25 per minute for the
hours spent with the gorillas tourists
actually who come to see the gorillas
understand why we've done that
understand that it's all about
conservation for these species and you
can even see it in the in the in the
last recent sessions that we did our
strategy has actually proven to be the
right way to do this we've seen a 26
percent increase in the number of
individual gorillas
so it's working both on the conservation
side and on the tourism side it's a
fragile success story critically
endangered for years now their status
has been adjusted to endangered the
latest census shows they're just over a
thousand gorillas spanning Rwanda Uganda
and the Democratic Republic of Congo
from just around 200 a few decades ago
but that still doesn't seem a large
number when you think that it's the
whole world's entire population of these
incredible animals Stephanie Decker
al-jazeera in the Virunga mountains
everyone